your dad's a superhero
no my dad can't handle hot wings
hey lizzy with my nine o'clock
sorry about the game but we're going to
have fun tonight
let me guess another i.t conference i'm
going to be back in a couple days
thompson hey mom dad has a work
emergency so can you come pick me up i
love it when you call me mom let's throw
a rager
what's happening
please don't touch
[Music]
this is so tight
it's some kind of superhero lair your
dad's a superhero
what no my dad can't handle hot wings
step step step into the spotlight check
this out
i have a crazy idea
and the crowd goes
stepping to the spotlight
please don't kill me
now that's fast
we got him
[Music]
whoever has this technology can do
anything
we gotta save my dad's attack before
they destroy the world
we got this
what are you gonna do tickle torture me
oh dude that was too long
that was way too long
whoa whoa don't you i'm the i.t guy i
was alerted to a security breach
why couldn't you tell me about your
secret identity how am i supposed to say
oh by the way some alien power source
chose me to be the guardian of the
planet
it makes you sound crazy right
yes
play time's over kids
prepare for war
[Music]
things are warm
yeah so hot you got the winter suit
[Music]
you